this is the the beauty of the midwife
meme is
the the genius and the idiot
come to the same conclusion so what is
the idiot approach
like that's actually how you can
divine the genius approach is you're
like what would an idiot do
everyone can reach for the idiot
approach yeah everyone has the
intellectual capacity to reach for the
yeah if i didn't know anything
this is michael seibel with dalton
caldwell today we're going to talk about
how overthinking is sometimes a
founder's biggest mistake so
dalton
this video was triggered by this amazing
meme that you made on fundraising advice
but before we get to the meme because i
think it's like one of the best memes
i've ever i've ever seen for fundraising
advice
let's start in general let's start in
general
um
how can overthinking be bad and when can
overthinking be bad
yeah i mean
i think that what people think being a
founder is is what they saw in like
watching the facebook movie or or
popular television where you know you're
like coding a lot and you know you're
making deals and screwing over your
friends um just kidding um but but in
reality
it's a lot of
feeling lost and being not sure what to
do and feeling stressed out a lot and
you're worried all the time
and so you tend to overthink everything
in every decision
you kind of think in circles over and
over and over again because you don't
have a boss you don't have constraints
when you're a startup founder right
there's no one really telling you what
to do so you're on your own
and so when you the experience of being
a startup founder it's to always be
overthinking everything in this way
there's a bit of an advantage to being
young right
yeah like you and i experienced this
ourselves as founders where we were
young when we first started and this is
the beauty of not knowing anything
the beauty of not knowing anything is
that you think everything is easy and
none of the innumerable reasons why
something might be hard or your startup
might fail even occurs to you you're
like oh yeah i'm i'm 22. like
everything's easy i can figure this out
right
and so again this this is like the the
midwife meme right where if you don't
know anything
your approach looks a lot like the
approach of people that are really good
founders yes and the worst place to be
is that you know just enough to know why
the things you're trying are hard and
the odds are stacked against you
and that freaks you out and so you think
about it a lot right yes so dalton one
of the most perfect examples of this is
actually elon musk and
why i think it's so perfect is that
depending on how you tell the story elon
looks like the dummy or the idiot right
like i'm sorry the dummy or the genius
right depending on how you tell the
story and it almost doesn't matter right
because he's winning
but you know to me the first example
that i always loved is that you know i
read some book about the starting of
spacex and
it started with elon going to russia
trying to buy like rockets
and like the russian government being
like
there's this american billionaire guy
who wants to buy rockets and kind of not
believing it but elon just looking
really serious so they like considered
it and like they eventually said no but
like
he got to talk to people about buying
rockets from them he's just a dude with
money he was like
go to russia buy rockets like that's
those are the extremes is that genius or
stupid i can't tell i can't tell and and
like with tesla itself like to me the
midwit is
is electric cars are good that's the
extreme electric car is good or on both
in the middle it's like no one has
successfully done a startup car company
since the 50s and every you know if you
look at all prior attempts to build an
electric car like there's all these
words
and the infrastructure the electric car
is good yeah yes
and i think the the one that we find
most funny which we'll see this video
we'll see if we stand the test of time
is is the boring company right drilling
holes under the ground so that you can
drive places faster
is very clearly the idiot one but like
it could be the genius one too
it's exactly it's a beginner's mind idea
which is like traffic is bad what if we
dug
a hole under the ground
to get to downtown las vegas and what's
funny is you read all the critiques of
this like the midwest stuff's like well
bus systems already exist and it might
be much more efficient to optimize uh
transportation you know there's lots of
words in the middle of that but you know
drill tunnel to avoid traffic
is certainly at the extremes yeah
and you kind of see him approach all of
his problems this way where
you can imagine
it being the same sort of ideas that we
like
mars is cool like yeah mars is cool like
this is the kind of stuff we come up
with as teenagers like all these ideas
yes
and the the hard work is in the
implementation
but the idea isn't very complicated and
like the v1 is kind of
simple-minded and if he was an
overthinker he would do he would rule
all the stuff out all this stuff is like
obviously a bad idea and anyone in the
midwest territory would rule out all
these ideas yes right
yes and they still do
they still do it's you know it's the
tesla short seller right
let's go through some examples of of the
midwife meme and
you have to start with the meme that you
made for yc founders so just to provide
context we're in the part of the batch
where yc founders start getting nervous
about fundraising whenever a founder
gets nervous they start overthinking
and whenever they start overthinking
they assault us with office hours on
topics
and dalton created this meme so that we
could fight back
what does the meme say yeah what the
meme is simple it's
the
the naive founder is like oh
i'm going to raise the amount of money i
need to succeed i need i need here's the
amount of money i need to raise for my
series a i ran a model and it's you know
eight hundred thousand dollars so that's
what i'm gonna raise that is the like
naive approach
um
the really smart three
three time founder someone that's done
this before is like
i need to raise 800 000 so i'm going to
do it
and then the midwife is the one who
wants to
ask 15 questions and try to construct
the perfect round and be afraid that
someone they may not have enough
allocation for value-added investors and
they want to not have a signaling risk
they talk a lot about signaling risk and
there's like all these factors
where i'll be talking to someone and
we'll be like 15 levels deep in a
hypothetical
for an offer that they don't have
right
and that's that's the midway man is that
like you're screwing yourself by
overthinking all this stuff instead of
just being like hey i need x dollars i'm
gonna raise it i'm gonna get back to
work
this comes up a lot with mvps
one of the questions that i love getting
from a founder is before
um we launched our mvp
how do we know we're going to be able to
survive the onslaught of traffic and
users that will come
on our launch day
what what what's what's midwid what's
the midwife play what's the midwife meme
for for your mvp
i mean
yeah the the the two extremes of the
midwife meme are
launched
something
fast
build something fast and put it out and
the minute one is like well
i don't want to get a bad reputation
that my thing was buggy and we only have
one shot to launch and you know
like what about the press we got to do a
press launch it doesn't have to be an
event
yeah i don't want people to see my idea
and copy it so it's got to be perfect
yes that's one and then do we do do we
do like a techcrunch post or is it
better to try to get the new york times
or like what about hacker news yeah we
need to get all three so how do we
coordinate them together
we want to we want to be featured in the
new york times and so how do we optimize
for that or
oh what should we name the company how
about yes i don't
yes we have to rebrand because there's a
name that's kind of similar to ours we
don't want people to be confused
how about co-founders i hear this a lot
like
i
i am a business person and i'm good at
sales i need to find a marketing
co-founder and
an engineer like a cto who's already
managed 50 people because we're going to
grow fast
like how how does co-founder yeah it's
like
yeah dalton um i'm open to the idea of a
co-founder i just haven't found the
right person and what i really am
looking for is someone with at least
five to seven years of experience at
google
who made it to at least a level seven
and so you know i'm looking i haven't
found the right person yet but we're
looking for it yes when we find them i'm
i'm totally open to bringing out a
co-founder when i find that one but
first we're gonna raise money and then i
think that'll attract a better
co-founder yeah yeah so again the point
we're kind of making is not that any one
of these ideas is the one people say
it's that
it's thinking in circles and having a
thousand different reasons
yes that it's the person that should be
your co-founder is
no one that you currently know yes yes
right and then and let's talk about the
other sides of the equation right the
the
on the dumb side the founders like it's
fun to work with my friends so i'm just
to say my friend
on the smart side justin likes to put a
camera on his head you know let's go
this is our guy
like we were talking about why didn't
they pick you as your is their
co-founder wasn't it like because i i
helped them find an apartment and open
there we go
this guy
this guy helped us find an apartment all
right he's the co-founder of twitch done
there you go done
and then like
those super smart experience founders
like oh having co-founders viable for
emotional support i know this is going
to be tricky and like they have all the
like sophisticated reasons same answer
same answer i love that okay
next this is a classic one especially
because you have to deal with so many
admissions questions
applying to yc dalton what is what is
the
what is the jedi founder move and to
apply to yc versus the midwife
yeah the
the extremes of this and the midwife
meme are
i filled out my application and
submitted it
like like i applied
and the midway founder is like gee i
don't know if now is the right time to
apply i don't know if we're ready
oh i'm gonna i'm gonna write a draft of
my application and to send it to 15
people and i'm going to get feedback on
my application and i'm going to like
you know oh i need an introduction to
alumni and i need to talk to alumni and
i need recommendations yeah
recommendations from strangers that
don't know me
i i'm gonna do a lot of research like
you see you talk to people that like
put months of effort into their
application to yc strategy
yes
not correlated with success
and then you talk to people and they're
like oh yeah i just like filled it out
in 30 minutes and
i got in
yeah
and i spent all that other time working
on my
company and to be clear we're not saying
do a bad job on your application we're
just saying
trying to tweak out on this is like
something that you can spend tons and
tons and tons of time on
i'm not sure that's a great allocation
of resources
no you didn't i think that's like maybe
the essential point here is that like
we want you to spend time on the
important stuff for your startup like
we're trying to get you to avoid
spending time on the things that won't
help you
that's the idea that's the idea all
right
next and and here's here's kind of a
classic one is product market fit
dalton do i have product market fit
and how what's the midwife approach to
yeah the midwife approach for this one
is
to be not sure if you have it
and create 15 different metrics and like
a complicated series of thoughts that
maybe you have it or you have early
product market fit
versus the extremes on this meme earlier
we have some islands got earlier
the extremes of this are like
am i overwhelmed with demand like you
know it when you see it like you don't
have to think very hard when you have it
it's sort of like hits you over the head
when you have a product market i think
the extremes in the meme is like did i
sleep last night
it's like i didn't sleep last night do i
have time to wonder if i have product
market fit that's yes if you have time
to wonder about it if you're like gee
do i a product market fit let me let's
pontificate on this that probably means
you don't yes let's do some let's make
some reports so
so
we talk about all the situations where
maybe overthinking is not a good idea
but you also describe you know there are
certain situations you call them trap
door decisions when maybe you want to
think a little bit harder than that
before making a move so what are some
examples of those yeah so
um
legal issues
don't break any law like saying you
didn't know there was a law is not a
great legal defense
um regulatory issues
similarly oh i didn't know
that i couldn't launder this money um
probably
not great you may want to overthink that
and look into it um
things that affect people's health and
well-being
yeah you should overthink that you
should really spend the time
worrying about people right man like
let's not be fast and loose if we're
building an online pharmacy let's let's
measure twice cut once total and and i
think that um
what really good founders do is they are
very good at figuring out are they
dealing with something like that or are
they not because even within legal right
there's certain things that are like oh
this is like whatever and there's
certain things that are like really bad
michael should i file patents for all of
my ip
exactly that's a classic
overthinking probably not
so i think that like
the framework here
is really twofold one
don't overthink when you don't have to
and then two
um remember that like
most of the work
most of the work
is not in these overthinking games like
most of the work are not in these
over-optimizing games yeah it's action
action and not thinking right yes yes
it's launching it's getting the first
customer it's selling it's like it's
doing these things yourself
and that's counterintuitive because i
think that founders understand
that startups are really hard so they
assume you need complex strategies to
succeed
and it's like ah that's a hard thing
right it makes sense when i say it right
this is hard we would need a complex
strategy right
how do you respond to that it's like
what actual kind of strategy do you need
i think if you haven't seen
really successful startup companies
either personally like where you were
the founder of one or you know people
and you saw them go through it yeah it's
hard to believe how silly these things
are when they start
like i think unless you've literally
witnessed it personally and you've seen
the silly [ __ ] that goes on and like how
what it really takes to get big
your brain rejects the idea
yeah that that's actually how these
companies got built you're like no not
true it had to be like lots of strategy
meetings and white boarding you know
flow charts and you know um
gartner magic quadrants of like like
like i think you really your brain won't
allow you to see
that
actually here's a nice way to say it is
you know the term beginner's mind
you want to have a beginner's mind yes
that's what the midwife meme is and a
beginner's mind is like
i guess
i'm going to build a product and i'm
going to give it to people i guess i'm
going to deliver burritos you know
that's that's a beginner's mind approach
yeah
that's the game and so you might find
yourself
after watching this video asking
yourself what do i need to unlearn
yeah how can i have a beginner's mind
because again this is this is the the
beauty of the midwife meme is
the the genius and the idiot
come to the same conclusion so what is
the idiot approach
like that's actually how you can
divine the genius approach is you're
like what would an idiot do
[Laughter]
everyone can reach for the idiot
approach yeah everyone has the
intellectual capacity to reach for the
yeah if i didn't know anything
so
with all that being said um
have fun
and don't overthink it too much don't
overthink it too much and make sure
that you have a little bit of something
in your head that's asking yourself is
this the thing that's really important
if not i can move on
if not i can move on all right thanks
much alton
thanks